okay really okay both you guys need to
calm down we're not supposed to see him
more than twice in one week all right
you're seeing this chick twice in one
day dude relax invite her up there man
she's not gonna talk about Xbox I'm
gonna be sitting here being like I have
to fart but maybe I can't right now she
better have some hot friends dude you're
pissing me off open the door I don't
care gettin wasted hey hi oh we're not
interrupting no yeah interrupting I'm
not interrupting so uh this is uh this
is daniel it's mikey we went to college
together guys le daniel is manipulative
ian oh there we go hey honor man where'd
you guys go we totally lost marshmallow
back there hey we were just talking
about you all good things all good
things
this is not making much of a difference
is it hey son what is this James you not
tell me I was getting a jacket in the
car oh oh whoa what's with the tightness
dri-fit compression shirt keys my body
dry the wicks the moisture put that
jacket on don't take it off okay i'm not
i'm michael sweating it either let's go
keep my body John wicks it let's go wait
for my goals on oh I'm not gonna need
gloves I had a feeling i'll need those
Scott and finally we have your sculptor
sergeant Walter Garfield I work with
them on the world war 1 memorial in st.
Louis uh-huh salud hey how are you old
boy hey Walter how they treat you been
taking it pretty easy on us I think you
feel sorry for us old guys I know much
fancy an obstacle course it's not so bad
by the end you're just crawling on your
belly while the teenagers shoot blanks
over your head
light sequence flame tests and games
dramatic entrance Lord business I know
the special got away but don't be so
serious where's the other guy hey hey
hey buddy I missed you Oh teach you
really have I ever shown you my relic
collection nope I don't think you have
nobody knows where this stuff comes from
this one is the cloak of ban dai eat I
hear it's super painful to take off you
want to try it on